is joey fatone replacing joe gatto on
impractical jokers or will the empty
spot in the tenderloins be filled by
someone else want to know what other
celebs may be in the running keep
watching in december 2021 joe gato of
impractical jokers announced he would
depart the long-running true tv series
unfortunately this was no practical joke
and the remaining cast members have
pushed forward without their longtime
friend by their side pranking
unsuspecting victims gato have been on
the show since his founding in 2011
along with his pals brian q quinn james
mer murray and sal volcano the four
would venture forth usually in new york
city but they would make fools of
themselves in public making people
uncomfortable in the process
my wife was a rat my wife was a rat and
i'm a little cheeseboy now currently i'm
a little cheeseboy
it was all in the name of good fun and
the gang certainly produced numerous
laughs over the years both for
themselves and the millions of viewers
watching at home starting part way
through season 9 joe gatto left the
series and the remaining cast members
have ventured forth without their friend
in his place they brought on various
guest stars including comedians eric
andre and colin jost a situation begs
the question of whether someone will
enter the fold to replace gato for good
he has everything we know so far about a
prospective gato replacement finding a
new joker to join the ranks of the show
would be no easy task they would have to
find someone who vibes well with the
current cast members and has no problem
making a fool of himself in public as it
turns out the guy's already had someone
in that wheelhouse in the form of former
and sing singer joey fatone he's
appeared on numerous episodes and
specials over the years having no
problem getting in on the action himself
catone even hosts the aftershow
impractical jokers after party which
sees the guys break down their favorite
moments from episodes as well as
offering bonus content to viewers it's
obvious he has a lot of fun on the show
but would he make a good permanent
co-host to take joe gatto's spot a lot
of the uh a lot of the stuff i learned
on the dog whisperer works for her
fatone was actually asked about such a
development at the fandemic dead 2022
panel in atlanta he was questioned as to
whether he would consider replacing joe
gatto permanently on the show he
responded coily but honestly saying heck
yeah i'd love to but it's joe joe is the
man on that one let's be real all of
them are but he had no fear whatsoever
that dude did not care and he's good at
it he's really good at it so yeah i'll
probably come out and do stuff so if the
tome wouldn't do the show full time who
would be next in line there are a ton of
noteworthy comedians out there who would
likely love the opportunity to pall
around with the jokers however gato
brought something special to the
proceedings
for starters the four of them had been
friends for years prior to getting a
show
and you can't fake that kind of
chemistry
gato also became well loved throughout
his time on the prank show for his
boldness and willingness to do
everything and anything for a laugh
that's why it may not come as much of a
surprise to hear that there are no plans
to include a permanent fourth host on
the show anytime soon
james murray did an interview with
staten island advance where he was asked
about gato and the prospect of replacing
him while murray explained how the show
was definitely different he elaborated
he's irreplaceable so he didn't even try
to replace him that's the idea since
he's such an integral part of the heart
of the show he can't be replaced he
won't ever be replaced there will never
be a fourth member like that since this
departure the show is instead opted for
one-off celebrity co-hosts but it sounds
like that will be the system they
implement for the foreseeable future
murray went on to say the show is still
hysterical it's different it'll always
be different but it's still hysterical
and i'm just glad to still be doing it
with my best friends anyone who's
watched the most recent episode knows
all too well how funny the series has
remained so while viewers hold out hope
for gato's return at least they have
plenty of hilarious guest star antics
with the rest of the crew to tide them
over
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one